[Musique]
c'est l'événement politique de l'année
en russie
1895 journalistes accrédités une
conférence de presse marathon où tout
est permis ou presque pour attirer
l'attention du président poutine
[Musique]
si plusieurs questions ont porté sur les
changements climatiques ou sur les
accusations contre donald trump que
poutine a qualifié d' histoires
inventées c'est une question sur son
avenir politique à lui et sa succession
qui a entraîné toutes sortes de théories
nino's et les dix minutes comme si tout
cela serait-il prêt par exemple à
modifier la constitution du pays qui
limite à deux mandats consécutifs
la présidence en russie lui a demandé la
journaliste de l'agencé pro kremlin rià
novosti vladimir poutine a pour la
première fois a répondu que oui pourrait
faire c'est éliminer le qualificatif
consécutif a dit le président une
déclaration énigmatique qui entretient
le doute quant à ses intentions ne
s'accrocher au pouvoir en 2024 ou pas
pour plusieurs observateurs comme celle
des markov poutine se garde aujourd'hui
une porte grande ouverte
tout va bien en russie dit-il poutine
sera plus qu'heureux de partir et
laisser sa place à une nouvelle
génération politique
[Musique]
si les pays de l'ouest continuent leurs
regards hybrides contre la russie
poutine restera c'est évident dit le
politologue et ancien conseiller du
kremlin
et à écouter le président russe qu
parler aux journalistes pendant plus de
quatre heures les tensions entre la
russie et l'occident sont loin d'être
résolus l'année 2019 aura été bénéfique
certes pour le président qui continue
d'étendre son influence dans des pays
comme la chine la libye et la syrie
mais en russie il continue lentement
mais sûrement de perdre en popularité
2010 aura été marquée par des
manifestations contre la répression
politique et une économie qui tourne au
ralenti
monsieur poutine en est conscient dit
sergueï markov il poutine c'est très
bien aussi qu'avec un taux d'approbation
de 68% après 20 ans au pouvoir
il demeure plus populaire que tout autre
chef d'état qu'il s'est est depuis des
animations en bonne chose si thammarat
intéresse qu radio canada